learning new details about the russian
cyber gang suspected of shutting down
a major meat processor this week and
staging other attacks in recent past
there's also a debate tonight about
whether private businesses or the
government
are most responsible for failing to do
enough
to prevent them national security
correspondent jennifer griffin reports
tonight
from the pentagon good evening jennifer
good evening brett the department of
justice since
sent guidance to u.s attorneys offices
across the country today
elevating investigations of ransomware
attacks to
the same priority as fighting terrorism
these investigations will now be
centrally coordinated
with a new task force in washington
u.s law enforcement says the
russian-linked cyber gang known as
r evil is responsible for the hack on
jbs
the group made its presence felt in 2020
releasing 2.4 gigabytes of lady gaga's
legal documents
in april it carried out a ransomware
attack on an apple supplier
demanding 50 million dollars today the
white house tried to shift the blame
to the private sector business leaders
have a responsibility
to strengthen their cyber defenses to
protect the american public
and our economy deputy national security
adviser anne newberger
issued a memo outlining how companies
can protect themselves from what are
usually
simple spear phishing emails quote there
are immediate steps you can take to
protect yourself as well as your
customers and the broader economy
the nation's top cyber experts say the
u.s government has not done enough to
deter these attacks
these are criminal groups operating
independently
seeking to make money but they're given
sanctuary and protection by the russian
state
we're only seeing the ones that make it
into the public eye
there's hundreds if not a low thousands
of these attacks every year
jbs said it's on schedule to resume
production at all of their meat packing
facilities today
it's not clear if the company paid a
ransom colonial pipeline recently paid a
4.4 million dollar ransom to another
group of russian cyber criminals
james lewis says the last two
administrations and the current one have
been too cautious in their response
that's part of why the russians think
why should i stop i'm making a lot of
money and the americans aren't going to
do anything we need to make a move
putin just isn't afraid of us and that's
what the president has to change
lewis says the timing of the latest
cyber attacks so close to the summit
between president biden
and putin is surprising historically he
said there's been a cease-fire
in the weeks leading up to meetings like
this
today russia announced it is ditching
the u.s dollar as part of its sovereign
wealth fund
knowing the biden administration could
impose new sanctions
the justice department seized two
internet domains this week
used in spear phishing attacks that
mimicked email communications
from usaid at the state department brett
jennifer griffin live at the pentagon
jennifer thank you